this morning france seized a british
trawler and the country's maritime
minister said the two countries may not
be at war but they are in a fight
this is the boat that it's that's at the
heart of the row it's now being held in
the french port of love the scarlet
vessel belongs to macduff shellfish
they've denied fishing illegally and say
they have become a pawn in the dispute
let's speak to our europe correspondent
now who joins us from the french coast
adam what is the latest
well as you said we have what is a a
pretty rapidly escalating diplomatic row
over something that on the face of it
seems
fairly trivial in the great scheme of
things and that is a relatively small
number of boats from france who have not
been given a license to go into a
certain coastal water zone 6 to 12 miles
off the uh the coast of the uk and some
around jersey now those talks about
licenses are going on pretty patel the
home secretary has said that she wants
to see them continue the european
commission is the mediator there and yet
the french government has decided that
things have just dragged on for longer
than they can tolerate they say that
they have reached their limit
and they said that they were going to
introduce reciprocal uh effectively
revenge measures on tuesday of next week
which would involve uh checks on
enhanced checks at customs and also
british fishing vessels being banned
from ports like this one uh this is uh
balone
very very important for british fishing
uh fishing vessels now the french say
that uh that they haven't been granted
the licenses they deserve now the uk
says they've granted 98 of licenses to
eu vessels the french say that's
disingenuous but actually it's the
french were really suffering uh and that
there are vast number of licenses
outstanding the uk denies this and today
uh a british fishing vessel the cornelis
uh has been taken in as you said into
the half under french maritime patrol
uh
out
vessel and has effectively been seized
now it faces legal action french say
that it was fishing without a license
the owners of that vessel deny that so
that they consider this to be a
vexatious
dispute
and this does have the capacity i think
to escalate quite significantly
we've heard from french fishermen who
already talking about the possibility of
a blockade where they might not need
that if the french authorities
block harbors
like this one and the uk which says that
this is disproportionate even illegal
action is talking about taking their own
reciprocal arrangements and at the
moment
as ever with political disputes you see
that both sides probably want a deal but
they're not giving themselves much
wriggle room when you have the french
maritime minister the french europe
minister both going on the airwaves this
morning talking about not just a battle
but saying you have reached your limit
effectively accusing the uk government
of lying then there isn't much space for
them to back down emmanuel macron the
french president has got an election
next year he wants the votes in northern
france he thinks fishing is a totemic
issue on the other side you've got a
british government which sees that in
the brexit debate fishing there too was
a very important
subject and goodness knows a year ago
when we were going through those brexit
trade negotiations look how important
fishing was there and also sprinkling
the ripples from the northern ireland
protocol
but on that one remember that idea about
it being determined by the rules of the
brexit trade agreement is also being
played out here uh british diplomats are
at pains to say that they think they are
sticking exactly to those rules but the
french want some kind of exception
exactly the sort of thing that european
nations complain about when they are
negotiating around the protocol the
simple fact is that at a diplomatic
level there is clearly enormous tension
between the uk and the eu but
specifically between the uk
and france who frankly are in a
diplomatic way look like a couple of
rams butting into each other at the
moment spoiling uh for a fight spoke to
union officials here in the past hour or
so that they really want a resolution to
this they say the fishermen from france
and britain need to co-exist they are so
close to each other they don't want a
blockade what they do want are licenses
and permits and an end to this row and
that deadline tuesday of next week only
five days away the french say they will
back down if they see significant
progress but really is that going to
happen in the course of 120
hours
neither side wants to be seen to blink
first
both sides i suspect want to see some
kind of resolution
okay adam thank you so much adam parsons
there are europe correspondents talk
doctors from bologna